alors je suis candidat parce que je fais
déjà un boulot de sénateurs depuis huit
ans dans la mesure où le sénateur sans
sodium c'est de s'occuper en particulier
des finances des collectivités
territoriales or moi je prétends en
faisant l'annulation de la ctm faire
revenir 500 millions d'euros dans les
caisses des communes de la martinique
300 millions parce qu'on a perdu une
collectivité on en avait 2 et 200
millions parce qu'on est plus rup région
ultrapériphérique de l'europe vont se
mettre 200 millions d'euros par an quand
je ne sais pas s'il existe parmi les
autres candidats
un autre type européen 500 millions
d'euros mais moi je vais y arriver les
sénatoriales se déroule dans le cadre
d'une ctm qui illégal complètement
illégale et par exemple les conseillers
territoriaux n'ont pas un grand électeur
si la 7ème et illégale donc il ya un
risque d'annulation de ces sénatoriales
ne faut pas oublier ça on a dix jours
après le 24 pouvoir faire appel
directement conseil constitutionnel les
grands électeurs je leur demande de
voter en menant en votant un moment je
leur demande de voter une motion de
défiance à l'égard de de la loi du 27
juillet qui nous a supprimé le
département la région